[Musique]
à soixante dix huit ans dans un autre
pays luis pourrait jouir d'une belle
retraite bien tranquille jouer de la
guitare et cultiver des cactus sébaste
an men ruiz ou encore travailler à temps
partiel dans la sphère familiale une
boutique de livres d'occasion qu'ils
aident à gérer depuis la maison sa
retraite moins de 200 de l'apa - après
une belle carrière dans la gestion
d'entreprises sur notre prise à fermer
il s'est retrouvé au chômage
il n'a pas pu cotiser davantage son
épouse martha touche un petit peu plus
elle avait son atelier de couture et
elle bénéficie de la retraite minimum de
base de l'état les deux ensembles n'y
arrive pas à la rigueur et le tir d'un
coup s'il n'y avait pas l'inflation
revenue de la librairie la location
d'une maison en banlieue ne suffisent
pas à payer le loyer de cette petite
maison dans un quartier plutôt bourgeois
la seconde est sous le prix de
l'immobilier s'est enflammé ce sont
leurs deux enfants qui les aident à
joindre les deux bouts
comme pour hbo jose luis appelle cela
pudiquement la solidarité des familles
leur cas est typique au chili louis
c'est marthe a appuyé les manifestants
simply n'amène plein hamel les retraités
des enseignants les étudiants d'été par
un système privatisé à outrance ce sont
eux jeunes et vieux qui manifestent
contre la vie chère contre un système
qui enrichit de grands entreprises à
leurs dépens ils sentent qu'ils ne
reçoivent pas leur juste part
83% des chiliens les appuis étonnant
dans le pays le plus développé du
continent
le chili
et un développement économique
extraordinaire c'est vrai et le niveau
de consommation des filins a augmenté
dans les derniers 20 entendu mais d'une
manière incroyable
et qui dit consommation d'iodé tu mens
les chiliens vivent au dessus de leurs
moyens même s'ils sont plus riches que
les autres ils réagissent comme les pays
voisins en crise argentine brésil
équateur mal dans la rue ah oui bien sûr
les chiens ils disent toujours que nous
sommes différents mais peut-être pas si
différent non même
mais attention je pense que pas mal de
gens veulent pas perdre leur niveau de
consommation même s'ils gagnent peu et
le project au délai qu'ils prennent ni
té et l'alsace et la personne
le président sebastian pinera a dit
qu'il prépare un plan pour normaliser le
pays
il annonça projet de loi d'augmentation
des retraites de base de 20% qui
touchera 3 millions de personnes pour
martin louer ça veut dire 80 $ de plus
par mois
ils ne sont pas très impressionnés
jean-michel le prénom serait du canada